the year's coming to an end and the time
has come that video that tells you the
movies I enjoyed most this year that
yearly reminder to my viewers and
subscribers exactly who it is they watch
have I watched every movie in 2023 not
even close to I watch every movie in any
given year absolutely not but I do a top
10 list nonetheless because I cannot
have in you all think I'm some sort of
professional yes there were even a
couple movies that came out on Christmas
on Christmas Eve and Christmas and I was
really stressing out about it I was like
okay on Christmas Eve maybe I can dip
out early on visiting my brother then
watch a movie and do a video on that and
work on Christmas Eve and then on
Christmas I can dip out on family early
and then watch another movie and then
work on Christmas I was
like nope it's done I'm going to enjoy
family time on Christmas Eve and
Christmas then I'm going to do my top 10
video and I'm going to send 2023
packing gone that's the key to true
happiness my friends letting things slip
through the cracks and learning to be
cool with that also these are not
reviews of the movies I do have reviews
of these movies all but one all but
number 10 we'll get to that in a second
all right enough of this buildup
you know what to expect from my
top 10 videos we've been at this long
enough since there are a few things
worse than someone who prattles on too
much in the buildup of their videos
let's get to it my list of my top 10
favorite movies I watched in
2023 number
10 number 10's difficult because I found
nine movies I was comfortable with being
on this top 10 list the 10th I couldn't
find a movie I really felt was I didn't
feel like it was top 10 so whatever the
abyss re-release number 10 I'm actually
not with you today a movie that
was released in 1989 that was
re-released in theaters for one showing
on one day it's number 10 on my top 10
list not my first time watching The
Abyss first time watching The Abyss in
theaters as I sat there I was like by
God this is better than most movies I
watched in 2023 the making of the Abyss
is absolutely Infamous to say the least
but doesn't change the fact as I sat
there my old old man energy was coming
out as I thought why don't they make him
like this anymore if you haven't seen
the abyss yet now is the time to do it
it's lowkey one of Cameron's best all
right on to the other nine movies which
are actually from
2023 number nine a next up still they
gave me the man tiar I'm not going to
lie still is a documentary about Michael
J fox his life his career his
Parkinson's how he's dealt with that cuz
we've all heard stories about Michael J
fox the production of Back to the Future
his life when he started hiding his
Parkinson it's a different thing to hear
him actually talk about it he seems like
a likable dude who happened to find
success in that pit of vipers known as
Hollywood who maintains a perseverance
and optimism in the face of his disease
it's
inspiring number AG next up comic book
movie fatigue is not a thing because the
killer was great it's actually based on
a comic book a David Fincher film
starring Michael fast Bender about an
assassin I mean that just hooked me
right there you know what thing I love
about this movie is it feels like a film
that's at the beginning of a filmmaker's
career this movie kind of had the vibe
of a young upand cominging director from
the early 2000s the director that would
have a bright future that film that
would be a cult classic it had that Vibe
but from a seasoned director like David
Fincher long-winded way of saying David
Fincher has not lost a passion this does
feel like a passion project David
Fincher film releases used to be an
event I don't know how this one just
kind of snuck onto Netflix but the dude
still got it we knew we would but it was
refreshing number seven next up horror
movie of the year for me absolutely talk
to me there's a part of me that tries to
be conscious of the fact that part of
the story of the movie production itself
and the team who made it is part of what
grips me here YouTubers making a horror
movie that actually ended up being good
I can't help but root for that fact is
though the movie was actually good not
just good but it was great in October
people were like hey what's a good
horror movie I'm like talk to me that's
the one the acting chills Thrills creep
Factor all there it's a refreshing spin
on something that could have felt cliche
but feels new and wraps up in a way I
felt was actually pretty
thought-provoking and intriguing what
more do you want number six next up well
another monologue about comic book movie
fatigue not being a thing cuz across the
spiderverse was also great these
spiderverse movies are fantastic it's
also pretty refreshing to see a
Multiverse movie in a world of a lot of
Multiverse movies use that Multiverse
premise in a way that actually serves
the plot rather than just being like hey
Nostalgia bait what can we cram in here
it does have cameos for the sake of
people being able to be like oh hey I
get that reference but it was treated as
icing on the cake rather than trying to
be the whole cake itself 2023 was
definitely the year where I was like I
am officially sick and tired of movies
that feel like half of an actual movie
cuz it's part one and well part two will
come out later I guess this is the only
only movie on this list that did that
but that just shows it was in fact that
enjoyable number five next up killers of
the flower moon when I heard Martin
scors say he was doing a film in 2023 I
was like all right I'm in when I heard
the premise I was like that sounds dark
and up this was an epic an
odyssey a tragedy for being what was it
3 and 1/2 hours long the movie is
enormous three is the new too in terms
of cinematic hours of runtime this was a
movie that had really good time
management I felt it's a Masterwork by a
master filmmaker it's one to remember in
2023 number four in a world where
recency bias is absolutely a thing
another thing you got to be conscious of
when making these lists my answer to the
ironclaw is it absolutely deserves to be
on this list this is a heartfelt story a
heart-wrenching story it's tough to
watch but I don't mind saying this a
necessary watch the thing I appreciate
about movies like this is when they
revolve around a sport but you don't
have to be a fan of the sport in order
to connect to the story everybody in the
movie did a great job in fact I didn't
give everyone their due props so allow
me Jeremy Allen White Harris Dickinson
Mora tyy Stanley Simmons Lily James as
well as Zach Efron and Hol mccy who I
did give props to in my review yeah this
one will stick with me for a while
number three Oppenheimer had to be on
this list when I heard Christopher
Nolan's making a movie about Jay Robert
Oppenheimer I feel like
the feeling was unanimous right that
just sounds like why we go to movies
turns out when you watch the movie it is
in and of itself a celebration of Cinema
the script has flipped it used to be
this movie has so many CGI shots that's
how great it is Nows this movie has no
CGI shots even the explosions practical
that's how great it is Oppenheimer is
Christopher Nolan also being a seasoned
filmmaker but making a film that
showcases love for Cinema as large L as
you possibly can in as Grand scale as
you can Killian Murphy crushed it the
cast was enormous and vast Robert Downey
Jr and Oppenheimer was kind of like
Robert dairo in killers of the flower
Moon where it's like you don't have to
put in this much work we know what you
can do you could have just phoned in for
a paycheck but you didn't this is
probably on the technical level the best
movie on this list but there are other
movies that just speak to me personally
and those remain number two
all right we've come to the top two I'm
not going to lie I've gone back and
forth on the top two I've swapped them
around so many times in making this list
but in reality I've done the same thing
to the top four they've shuffled all
around so much we'll see how it lands in
the final product of this video as it
stands right now number two Godzilla
minus one for longtime Godzilla fans
this is probably number one and you
would be right to say so but for me I
expected nothing out of Godzilla minus
one Godzilla never gripped it's just one
of those things I missed out on growing
up then the Americanized Godzilla
Godzilla Kong movies they've come out
and I'm like okay well they happen then
I watched this and I was like wow so
this is what Godzilla is supposed to be
I always saw the old Japanese Godzilla
movies as cheese this took all of the
cheese out and just made something Grand
and epic humans you actually care about
dealing with struggles that grip you
also a monster that threatens their
lives and ability to rebuild another
thing I loved about it it was the people
that came together to take out Godzilla
it was on the people to save
themselves how could you not love that
Underdog Story yeah I was impressed this
is the first movie that made me feel
like I missed out in not being a
Godzilla fan earlier in my life but such
is life an absolute badass movie of
2023 number
one and number one objectively Speaking
is probably not better than the previous
three that I listed but I really love me
a good ending to a story so John Wick
chapter 4 John Wick is proof that you
can make a new original Ip that's not
based off of a comic book and have it be
a modern classic the action sequences
clean the gun love out of control you
know thing I have loved about these John
Wick movies up through four is it hasn't
felt like copy and paste you can only do
so many different things when it comes
to fighting and shootouts but every
installment feels fresh it feels
different than the previous ones there's
that top down scene like I said in my
review it reminded me of Hotline Miami
in a world where action movies are a
dime a dozen John Wick came along and
just it gave me something that felt new
John Wick chapter 4 kept that torch
going it's not just action it's action
with a very specific style it's stylish
it's classy slick suits cool weaponry
and again I appreciate a story that has
the guts to end so many stories just
keep going until they fizzle Into
Obscurity they limp along until no one
cares anymore and it just becomes sad
John Wick chapter 4 I felt was a great
ending to John Wick's story I've heard
rumors about a five I don't see how you
do a chapter five without ruining John
Wick chapter 4 so don't do that it is
nearly 3 hours of violent action movie
Extravaganza what can I say left me
fulfilled which is why John Wick chapter
4 that's number one in 2023 for me so
that concludes my list of my top 10
favorite movies of 2023 thank you all
for watching this video and thank you
all once again for yet another year of
me doing this I've said it before and
I'll say it again it's 100% true without
you watching me there's no me doing this
this next year in 2024 July
2024 you ready for it it'll be 15 years
of me talking movies on YouTube that's a
bafflingly long time to think about
especially when you're talking about
YouTube life for a channel like I get it
me my channel I'm not for everybody so
I'm glad I continue to work for people
who do like my stuff I'm very conscious
of that and very thankful for that so
again thank you thank you for another
year all right so your top 10 favorite
movies of 20123 or five or three however
many you want to list or maybe you just
have one favorite that's cool whatever
it is whatever they are whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more